when when men meet a new girl and they  say to the boys i've met a new girl and  the boys say what does she look like  right  when  women meet a new man when we say i've  met this new guy guys what does he do  which is totally different so women want  to know what this guy can do and men  want to know what she looks like i think  we asked both i was pretty like what'd  he do yeah i think it always what you  look like first because you need to know  what it looks like then it's like oh  what does he do but it's very important  in in a woman's conversation when he  does that i don't i don't think that i  don't think that's true you wouldn't ask  what he looks like yes i would yeah what  does he look like go on what's up show  me his picture 100 yeah i'm not  obviously i'm not a girl but i do you're  initial though would it be the first  thing you ask